dealing chassis drive this both the deal
and man in the wasp teaming up so I
think it's safe to say that a lot of
ant-man fans were upset that ant-man
wasn't in infinity war but are we really
sure man wasn't an infinity war
yeah I know I've said how do you know I
wasn't really really small and you just
couldn't see me in some of those scenes
and then if we're following that theory
technically ant-man could have been in a
lot of Marvel movies maybe a man's been
in every Marvel movie and maybe it was
even before Scott Lang maybe was Hank
Pym maybe it was ink pen should we start
some should we start burning up the
internet right now and so it with some
theories yeah let's do it Hank Pym was
in every single Marvel film no are you
allowed to say let me tell you something
Hank Pym was in Howard the Duck that's
how far back hold on
you gave her wings and blasters so I
take it you didn't have that tech
available for me you know I did you have
been D aged for this movie is that weird
seeing your younger self on screen it's
fun I mean first of all let's talk about
Michelle Pfeiffer I find out in the
movie chef Michel fibers a met my wife
but I said wait a minute
we're gonna be 40 years younger well as
beautiful as Michelle Pfeiffer us today
she looked pretty damn good 40 years so
it's it's it's exciting look forward to
that I think it's just one of the magics
magics of Marvel I've never done one of
these CGI
superhero pictures before so for me this
is an education just can't believe they
put these little dots all over your face
and you act and then next thing you know
you've lost 30 years it's like free
Botox is free Botox exactly that's what
he's crazy could be gold so that walks
two walls of stuff
slowly otech
now so much to take over the world or
whatever close thing about ghosts is
that we saw it in the comics as a foe
for Iron Man but ghost never really had
much backstory which i think is cool
because you guys kind of created this
character from scratch so did you have
any ideas for ghost that was
incorporated into the character well I
mean it's amazing cuz you know it's it
that you're right it was with Iron Man
and there wasn't a lot you know to go on
but also at the same time it's a male
character and I had the honor to take
the character lift it off the page and
and give it wings and give it life so
yeah it was amazing to sit down with
Peyton and and basically sit and talk
about who is she and why how and so that
was yeah that was the fun part is kind
of really sitting down figuring out who
the character isn't and then and then
creating it from there thanks to you we
had to write
we're still running let's go I've seen
you describe this franchise is weird I
read that somewhere I might have used
the word weird yep so I want to know why
do you think the ant-man franchise is
weird I mean weird and only a most
positive sense of the word weird I think
we've created a world in the ant-man
movies where almost literally anything
can happen and in the first movie with a
man there's a lot of shrinking down and
now we're playing with all these
different sort of sizes and using that
Pym technology to shrink and grow cars
and buildings and stuff and it's all
juxtaposed to the real world in which we
live it's not an outer space or on an
Asgard or anything like that and so it
makes the world around us seem fresh
again because weird stuff is going on
like you know right around the corner or
right under our noses I think that's
really what I mean weird and it can be
comedic ly weird too like we we do some
very strange comedic things in this
movie do you prefer to play giant man or
ant-man well you can have some real fun
with a giant man cuz can't really do it
all that long before you start getting a
little loopy but you can do a lot of
really cool things when you're you know
ant-sized practically I don't like
playing either one of them because I can
sit that one out and they can just do it
on the computer and then that's always
nice to be in a scene and not have to
actually film it cuz I'm a lazy person
help yourself it was about the fancy
pastry we got to keep the food budget
down well what are we supposed to have
for breakfast the oatmeal packets Oh
milk tank is insult why is it insult
because it tastes like sin you know why
it's organic no gimmick it's it's the
most important meal of the day you know
what you can get creative with it great
teeth I'll put a little brown sugar on
it you put some cinnamon put a little
honey you guys guys come on
man why should people go see this movie
I think it's for a couple of reasons one
to see wasp
this is her coming-out party as a hero
I'm really really excited and proud that
you know to have this sort of the first
female hero character in the MCU and the
title of a movie and Evangeline is
amazing I think it's a good time in the
movie we wanted to make something that
was
even funnier than the first movie and
there may also be some some tips to the
overall larger Marvel Cinematic Universe
that people may be interested in to this
particular one and the Marvel compared a
lot of the other mild films it's like
family oriented it really revolves
around the fact that hank pym my
character is telling his daughter
Evangeline Lilly about the loss of her
mother and the possibility of finding
her so sort of grounded any getting
together family story so I guess we're
you know we're sure like The Incredibles
oh that on the peerage it's filthy they
have bigger problems it's the first
titled female character in an MCU movie
and the more people that sit in the
seats the more that not just MCU but
every studio will realize that that is
what people want to see and they will
make more movies with female superheroes
in the title but aside from the politics
aside from where your money goes is what
you know what you get back the movie is
fun it's heartfelt it's emotional it's
sweet it's relatable and I think in this
moment culturally and politically when
so many things feel dire so many things
feel very troubling and dark and and I
think people are looking for hope it's a
very hopeful film it's a very sweet film
that you'll go away from I think feeling
good and feeling like hey if you know
hope Van Dyne and Scott Lang or just
ordinary folks can put on some suits and
go save the day then you know maybe I
can too
[Music]
you